but I would say that where a company has
an opportunity to do something
substantial I think we have a moral
obligation to work on those subject if
Nestle and myself has become very vocal
in the area of water it was not because
of any philanthropic idea it was very
simple by analysing what is the single
most important factor for the
sustainability of Nestle water him as
number one subject and out of this
became the interest to analyze situation
of water and why it is not sustainable
and once we found out the truth about
this over exploitation of water we
started to create first awareness and
then secondly started to create a group
of people who would have the same
interest brought them in their different
NGOs we brought in the big institutions
and today we have I would say a whole
group of institutions companies which
are working actively on the problems and
hopefully as I mentioned before have
brought forward solutions practical
solutions in order to overcome such an
important issue I think this is part of
a company's responsibility now if I was
in a different industry I would have a
different subject certainly that I would
be focusing on but that's the area where
at Nestle
we can do most and that's why which I've
chosen it at Nestle
yeah because it is in the interest of
our shareholders that's that I mean if I
want to convince my shareholders that
this industry is a long-term sustainable
industry I have to assure that all
aspects that are vital for this company
are sustainable now when I see like in
our case at one of the aspects which is
water which is being needed in order to
produce the raw materials for our
company if this is not sustainable then
my enterprise is not sustainable so
therefore I have to do something about
it
so shareholder interest and societal
interest are common